one cool thing about being a mildly
successful youtuber is that occasionally
I get an invite to a cool place and
earlier this year I got an invite to go
visit CERN which when I saw I was like
hell yeah so I booked a quick flight
over to Geneva and how to visit on the
day I went and saw one of the detectors
I went and saw the control center the
data center and also the magnet factory
so let me show you what I saw it's CERN
there's lots of names for lots of
different things I'll start with the
bird's eye view just to orient you this
is CERN a campus of buildings and load
of tunnels underground the border of
Switzerland and France there are many
different loops for accelerating
particles but the most famous and
biggest is the Large Hadron Collider the
LHC which is a large ring with two
proton beams circulating inside in
opposite directions
it's got four big detectors on it which
are placed over crossing point of the
proton streams when the proton streams
cross protons collide and energy is
turned into matter making massive
particles which then decay into a stream
of other subatomic particles
these detectors are made of many panels
of gas that detect when a particle
passes through them as well as loads of
electronics and magnets the point of
them is to track every single particle
that comes out of a collision I went
down and saw one of the detectors that
Atlas detector which was used to
discover the Higgs boson along with
another detector called CMS there are
other detectors to Alice which looks at
what happens when you collide lead atoms
into each other
yep you can lob lead atoms around the
Large Hadron Collider to when lead
collides it forms a crazy dense and hot
form of matter called a quark-gluon
plasma quarks and gluons are just other
kinds of particles and the other
detector is called LHCb and looks at
some other particles called beautii
particles the Atlas detector was
absolutely awesome to see in person
the higgs boson discovery such a big
deal in the history of physics so I felt
really fortunate to have gotten a chance
to see the detector up close for myself
and the thing that impressed me was not
only the sheer size of it and it was
huge but also the density of everything
you know there's loads of big things in
the world like buildings but not many
building sized things that are made of
solid technology there was electronics
detection panels pipes wires giant
magnets and all of that stuff has to
work together flawlessly they can't have
a single gap or a section that isn't
working because they need to be able to
account for every single decay product
of a proton proton collision so it was a
marvel of engineering to behold massive
and densely intricate and one cool thing
was the giant hole in the roof which is
where they lower down all of the bits of
the detector
the second place I visited was the
control center where there were four big
circles of computers and monitors and
loads of monitors with all the
information about the status of all the
different bits of the LHC it was really
quiet when I got here because they're
not currently running experiments right
now they're working on upgrading the
luminosity of the beams which means more
collisions per second with the
luminosity upgrade they're aiming to get
five times the rate of collisions and
ten times the amount of recorded data
the goal is to get more statistics on
the Higgs boson they've done the bit
where they discovered it but now they
really want to study it you see when you
create a Higgs boson there are a number
of different particles that can decay
into by measuring the probabilities of
it decaying in these different ways
scientists can test to see if the
standard model our fundamental
description of particle physics is
actually correct any deviation from what
the stand alone predicts would be very
interesting and it's kind of funny the
standard model of particle physics is
this incredibly good description of
harrow the fundamental stuff in our
universe works but as a theory it's
almost too good a theory because every
single measurement we make an experiment
we do agrees with the standard model and
this is kind of frustrating for
physicists because what they're doing is
trying to look for something that
violates the standard model and the
reason is because we know that there's
some stuff that the standard model can't
explain like how Dark Matter works the
gravitational force or why there's more
matter than antimatter in the universe
so if someone finds something that
doesn't agree with the standard model it
might lead to new physics that can
answer some of these questions that's
really what physicists are hunting for
so anyway when the beam is up and the
experiments are running this place would
be really busy but right now it was
quiet because everyone's away either
working on the upgrades or busy
analyzing the insane amount of data that
they've already collected I did see this
wall of champagne bottles and apparently
they have one champagne bottle for each
of the major discoveries that they've
made and this one's the specific
champagne bottle they opened when they
discovered the Higgs I'm pretty sure
they had more than one of these speaking
of the insane amount of data they
collect after lunch I visited the
computer center this is the place that
they collect
process all of the huge amounts of data
from the detectors the data center was
massive and split on two levels and also
incredibly warm the volume of data that
they have to handle at CERN is
absolutely mind-blowing imagine this
when the beams are circulating there are
600 million collisions per second each
one creating a shower of particles
that's picked up by the detector most of
these showers are not really interesting
because the protons haven't hit each
other at a small enough angle see
protons are very small so you get way
more glancing hits than direct hits
so the electronics throws away most of
the collision data immediately and only
passes about one in 10,000 collisions to
be stored in the computer memory but
even from throwing away so much data the
output of the detector is still a
colossal a hundred gigabytes per second
if you compare that to all the digital
data I've ever produced in my life which
is stored in this one four terabyte hard
drive a CERN experiment would fill this
up in 40 seconds and they run these
beams for years at a time so the amount
of data they have is staggering but they
don't keep everything as they still need
to filter out more of the data the
detector pit they do more analysis on
the collisions and throw out a further
99 percent and that last one percent
goes to their 280 petabytes of disk
storage that's 280 thousands terabytes
and for permanent storage they have a
further 340 petabytes of storage on
magnetic tape yes you heard correctly
magnetic tapes it turns out it's a
really good way of storing large amounts
of data and they also distribute the
data to other institutions around the
globe for storage and analysis studying
these Higgs bosons takes a huge amount
of work and I also saw the computer that
Tim berners-lee created the World Wide
Web
and the first browser which was kind of
cool then the final destination for my
visit was to their magnet Factory in the
LHC protons are traveling at 99.999999
1% speed of light so they need crazy
strong magnets to bend them to stop them
from crashing into the sides and then
they have some other massive magnets to
focus the beams right before they cross
to focus the collisions in fact this is
a big part of the luminosity upgrade
improving the strength of these focusing
magnets to create tighter bunches of
protons so that when the beams cross
there's a high probability of
significant collision events all of
these magnets are made from
superconductors cooled with liquid
helium when they do upgrades they need
so many magnets they have a factory
on-site there's several parts of making
these magnets which are really
interesting
they basically consists of many loops of
superconducting material which are all
glued together they need to be glued
together very strongly otherwise they're
just self explode and they're all so
weird because they don't really work the
first time you turn them on you have to
go through a process of training them
basically the first time you turn them
on they're a bit rubbish they don't
really go to a very strong magnetic
field so you have to turn them off and
on again several times and each time
they get much better
so in this factory they build these
incredibly strong magnets and train them
to go to really high magnetic fields and
for me it was really cool to see because
they used to do a lot of work in
low-temperature physics so it's great to
see a facility this huge so that was my
visit to CERN I had a really amazing day
there and a big thanks to all of those
people who took time out of their day to
show me around and you might be
wondering if you can go visit CERN and
in fact you can so on the 14th and 15th
of September 2019 they are having a
special open day where if you register
you can go and see some of the things
that I saw too so you need to go to
their website I've put the link in the
description below those two days is
extra special open days but if you can't
make it to those open days specifically
but you're in the area and want to go
visit they still have lots of things you
can see you just won't be able to go
have a tour of the underground bits and
if you want to watch some more videos
about the things that are going on at
CERN I really recommend a series of
videos that trace Dominguez has done on
his channel they look at the science
behind the luminosity upgrade and some
other things too they're really cool
videos and I've put a link to a playlist
in the description below so go check
those out and you may have noticed it's
been a little while since I've uploaded
to this channel what's the deal with
that well I
I've been working on some stuff in the
background so from now on there will be
one video coming out per month on this
channel plus the occasional sprinkling
of bonus content I've gone into more
detail about what I've been working on
in a video on my patreon and if you are
so inclined to support me on my mission
to explain science to the world there's
many ways to do so there and another way
is I have a dftba store where I sell
cool posters and some other things so
you can check that out too so I'll see
you on the next video to make sure you
don't miss it
subscribe to this channel and also if
you're so inclined bring the
notification Bell YouTube was there's so
many instructions I'm incredibly
demanding on you can choose to do any or
none of those things and I'll still be
uploading videos and you can watch them
at your own just live your life dude
it's cool alright see you on the next
video